antoine bonjour alors on l'a appris tout
à l'heure la demande de transfert d'alex
à une avanie a été acceptée c'est bien
ça où tout à fait c'est un véritable
revirement de situation tout s'est
déroulé à homs parce que après s'être
prononcé en défaveur d'un transfert
l'état du patient étant jugé trop
instable pour qu'il soit transporté le
médecin chef de l'hôpital dans lequel il
a été admis a finalement donné sa
bénédiction sur demande de la famille
vous propose de l'écouter c'est je
considère que l'état du patient comme je
l' ai déjà dit est suffisamment stable
depuis un certain temps et comme j'ai
reçu de nombreuses demandes de la part
des proches de permettre de transporter
le patient ailleurs et sachant qu'il ya
quand même encore certains risques les
proches l'épousé le frère du patient qui
contrait à moins vous sont complètement
informés et dispose de toutes les
données sur le diagnostic et l'état du
patient
ils portent de même la responsabilité
lié à ces risques
à ce moment là nous avons décidé de ne
pas les exposer à son transfert dans un
autre hôpital à celui que ses proches
nous indiqueront la viande locale d'une
ong qui est déjà posée à leur pardonne
que devrait donc pouvoir prendre en
charge avec senna vanille et le
transférer vers l'hôpital spécialisé
situé en allemagne
entre temps les proches d'alexandre ali
n'ont pas ménagé leurs efforts pour
tenter d'accélérer les choses
ta famille liée à naval naya a publié
sur les réseaux sociaux une lettre
adressée à vladmir poutine lui demandant
de faciliter le transfert de son mari
dans l'entourage a même fini la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme dans
l'après midi
alors est ce que ces différents recours
ont eu un impact sur l'agriculture des
médecins la question reste ouverte mais
quoi qu'il en soit désormais plus rien
ne s'oppose au transfert d'alex et la
vanité l'une des voix les plus critiques
envers le kremlin
merci beaucoup antoine claireaux antoine
claireaux notre correspondant en direct
de moss